[Music]
you're a thief and a liar I only lied
about being a thief first I mean I'm
doing great
to smile the Redis I don't like you
being held up be cool I don't do that
any steal lie I do some carry gun oh my
god
right
these says you've been too successful
you're bored complacent and drawing your
way down
what's going on I don't you do I would
show up at an airport look at the
destination board pick a place and go
head of the South channel as rocky neck
and pound island blow air horn roll wave
to the lighthouse keeper's kid - brother
[Music]
this mission is never designed to
succeed they tell us them with as many
people died who cares about our they're
wrong because that's exactly what we're
fighting for for our culture
a way of life but if you destroy their
achievements it's like they never
existed ah floating
and it's the one thing we simply can't
allow
[Music]
the favorite most important moments in
life
[Music]
[Applause]
wait
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]